we're going to begin with this this
morning a giant cargo ship is lying on
its side off the coast of Georgia right
now and rescuers are working very hard
to find everybody who was on board when
it capsized four people are missing
after the ship overturned and caught
fire early yesterday in st. Simon Sound
20 other crew members were rescued
federal investigators are still trying
to learn how the ship rolled over near
the port of Brunswick that's just north
of the Florida State Line meg Oliver is
on the scene meg what's the latest with
the rescue efforts good morning you can
see behind me exactly what rescuers are
up against this vessel nearly the length
of two football fields has turned over
on its side they haven't made any
contact with crew members missing inside
to help them do that searchers top
priority right now is to stabilize this
ship
the golden ray ran into trouble shortly
after leaving port early Sunday the
cargo ship carrying 4,200 vehicles began
listing heavily the advise
authentication system the shipper down
there are groomers on board a witness
noticed the huge freighter on its side
and dialed 911 to am one of this will
that brings in the cars it's with their
owners right rod 23 crew members and one
pilot were on board the ship when it
capsized in st. Simon Sound
sir Andrews reported within the ship's
whole racks at this point
Coast Guard video shows one person being
pulled to safety in the middle of the
night rescuers evacuated 20 of the 24
crew members before a fire made the
mission too dangerous smoke and flames
began to appear the situation was too
risky to further go inside the vessel to
attempt to locate the four individuals
who remain missing at this time
back on shore crowds gathered to watch
the Coast Guard operation to see it on
its side it was just so big so
surprising and it's just a huge crowd
down here Coast Guard officials say the
rescue mission can only resume once they
determined this ship is stable there's a
complex situation so you know we're
looking not just for the safety of there
to be able to rescue the people that are
on board but also to be able to provide
safety for our crew so it's ongoing
Hurricane Dorian brushed the Georgia
coast last week but officials say it's
unclear if weather conditions caused the
ship to list so heavily investigators
are looking into whether the ship's
stability was compromised when it left
port Meg thank you